Yuna is something I need in my future I need to somehow
rescue her
Devil, the delicious meat is grilled
Even if it's a devil, I'd rather have crispy and juicy
pork
Come on, let's put this in the pitfalls of our self-confidence and
do it
pork  I don't like
pork.
[Music]
Even though I'm being attacked, you're trying to eat meat.  I
'm glad Yuna is
safe.
Of course, you remembered me. It's been 3 years.
How have you been?
I thought you forgot, so I'm
happy to see Yuna-san's smile again I love Yuna-san's
smiling face,
so I nonchalantly persuaded Yuna-sama, "I love music"  I'm
doing it I'm telling you I'm going to help you Let's
do a barbecue What a change in your expression
Excuse me, what
is this sound? I'm
sorry, it's the sound of my
stomach.
[Music] The
man who saved the world died so easily